one of the things that you touch on that
I really like is that you need to love
yourself before you can learn to love
someone else and before you can allow
them to love you yeah and I I think you
need to be able to understand your own
values and what you will and will not
tolerate within yourself mm-hmm like
there's certain things that I've
realized are Keystone habits and
Keystone failures of myself and when I
get them right I feel ten times better
and when I get the wrong I feel ten
times worse but I never knew that I was
being triggered on those by partners and
I was projecting onto partners for a
decade yeah until I actually did a bit
of introspective work and then realize
that yeah holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like the
problem was never with that the problem
was with them but it was other things
yes but you knows you didn't especially
come out of relationship is where we
come out over teenage years none of us
are [ __ ] confident right even the
confident teenagers like deep down
weren't
oh yeah confident like we're all we're
all just [ __ ] balls of hormones
hormones and it secures them anxiety and
you know we're just filled up to her
balls with common we were horny and we
didn't know why and we didn't know what
to do and you said there you get to see
you're insecure and you you know they
suddenly go you're an adult especially
your teenager they were getting that
young adult you got a [ __ ] teenager
Armagh young I'm a child I'm a child I'm
28 and now I'm a young adult yeah I'm a
young adult only now is before that I
was a [ __ ] I was a child I how dare
you could have like I understood when I
was [ __ ] sick so it's like a young
adult full of [ __ ] no I was not and the
fact that you even let me believe I was
a young adult is ridiculous if you know
anything [ __ ] child abuse yeah and
then you get into it so you dawn love is
how could you don't know who you are and
the problem is when you get to a
relationship that is special when we go
into university I mean not like dead by
soft monks my friends is you go through
the same - really like - you're going to
change so much because you know you
don't really choose what [ __ ] high
school you go to or who your friends you
pick a friend of this randomly selected
of people in your [ __ ] area who
happened to be born in the same year
like none of them are you just friends
with them out of convenience I'm do it
you'll get friends for life and whatnot
but when you go to university there's a
lot more freedom to it you're gonna grow
naturally in nitin in university just
after high school we're going to change
so much and I feel like sometimes if
you're in a relationship there which you
would be because you're like oh God
here's this scaly new world that I'm a
[ __ ] adult and what do adults do or
adults or man it adults through
relationships what I'll do to be an
adult or get into a [ __ ] relationship
and I'll doing salad my parents days
which is compromising change and do
anything to make this relationship work
because that's what adults do and you
sit there and you create this false
version for yourself and it's not
malicious in any way the person that you
they're not changing you for bad reasons
you're like please change me I want to
do anything I love you and you make me
happy and I want to make you as happy as
you make me so I will change or
willingly change for you and then seven
years later you're like I don't even
[ __ ] like rock climbing [ __ ] hate
cheese and wine like why I watched Eat
Pray Love 75 and it's really hard
because that person that changed you
they didn't necessarily force you to
change I'm gonna make this kind of rock
climbing oh yeah you just decide I'll do
whatever makes you happy and you know
just hope something like like does like
being it's like being moldable puddi
right and and you're just so malleable
at that early age I mean I
okay that's confusing man when Italy
loves you do Anna's brother a person you
[Music]
you